so glutton my name is itching so I'm
currently running the data and AI
section for a speaker but one question
how many of you know a speaker on donor
okay so SP good is the utility company
in Singapore so they're running the the
bidding and metering and billing
services for household and every single
organization and we are managing the
transmission and diffusion network for
electricity and gas for Singapore good
so give you a big context so today I'm
going to share one of our works related
to anomaly detection from the IOT time
series Lisa agenda so I would start with
the problem the condition monitoring and
anomaly detection and maybe some of you
already familiar with auto-encoder but i
will still give a very brief
introduction on that and how it is used
for anomaly detection then I'll go into
our thinking about what what is the
challenge of directly applying
autoencoder
and how we explore a new idea and how we
designed it and I also will talk a bit
about the workflow because not just the
algorithm but how to automate how to
peel it as a service it's also important
for Co and I will end up with some
energy related use case to demonstrate
the performance and benefit of the
methods the let's now is the problem the
the condition monitoring and anomaly
detection so you you may know with the
progress of the IOT big data and AI so a
lot of industry a lot of company has
star or will continue to deploy a lot
more sensors to digitize their devices
equipments systems as well as the
business process so this is in the the
area of the so called industry 4.0 so
this is also especially true for the
energy and industrial space so for for
us for SP group actually we have a lot
of use case which we need a condition
monitoring so for example we need to
monitor or check the status of the
every single meters in every house to
make sure our metering and billing
services is accurate so for our district
cooling business we need to make sure
the cooling tower and chiller is
functional properly to provide the
cooling surprise for example right so
for the micro grid with new renewables
then we have new things that the solar
panel the energy storage system need to
functional properly to make sure we get
the most economic dispatch to provide
our to supply the energy and in terms of
our core business the the transmission
and distribution network then you have a
lot more conditional monitoring use case
we need to monitor the transformer a lot
of equipments inside the network right
so providing a better more condition
monitoring that will have our business
to improve our operation and make sure
our services is redriver
so let's the goal we want to achieve and
as one of the important step for the
condition monitoring is anomaly
detection so another attraction focus on
identify the data points that do not
conform the normal expected behavior of
the the system or the the process so in
general there are three type of the
anomaly detection methods so the manual
methods rely on the manual inspection
conducted by the human but it requires a
lot of human efforts so it cannot be
scale up to handle a large volume or
large number of the data and second that
this kind of impaction inspection work
is tedious and boring so the the
inspection quality normally were the
grace after the first initial period so
the staff may be very happy to do the
inspection for the first half first
month after that I think that it's not
sustainable right and second type of
method is the dual pace so in general
the the dual pace would like you will
set up the minimum and maximum value for
the measurement according to the OEM
spec so anything within the range is
team as a normal anything else our range
is thin as a normal but the the the
disadvantage of the rule-based method is
first these methods introduce a lot of
fuss
second this fixed setup is not adapt to
the different environment different
situation so just imagine the same same
type of equipments of the same brain
when they deploy into different
environment and the working condition is
different so it's time evolved right the
behavior of the equipment will be
different so some behavior in one
situation is a normal behavior but if
you shift to another environment the
meaning is different it is become a
normal so the Bloor cannot capture
additional things so that's why the
third category data-driven matters is
Creepers so instead of relying on human
inspection or loose discount method
we'll learn the common behavior of the
equipment from the data and detect
anything different from the common
behavior as normally but driving the
adoption of this data treatment methods
for anomaly detection is hard actually
because in a very cunning very often
situation if you ask the users they will
say okay I like The Economist I want an
anomaly detection but when you go into
the detail you ask what other what other
normally you try to detect they never
tell you I don't know I don't know what
kind of you I'm looking for then what
happens value you are tracked in there
so our solution to this actually we want
to provide a low-cost easy-to-use
outer-box solution to the users we want
them to explore as much as possible the
use case as the first stage then they
will give the feedback about some of the
low value use case they can directly use
the outer box solution for some other
use case if you need a very accurate I
mean more advanced solutions then you go
into a customization mode so today what
I am going to show is that our effort to
try to make a low-cost easy to use out
of box solution for anomaly detection so
auto-encoder is one of the common
methods being used for
anomaly detection so I may want to ask
the question how many of you know the
auto encoder okay so so few of them so I
will give a very quick introduction so
auto encoder is the type of neural
network with the encoder and decoder
architecture
so the idea of the auto-encoder it's
kind of self learning so here the self
learning means that the unlabeled data
is used as Lily the data itself is used
as the label to train the network to
learn how to reconstruct the signals so
the output of the network is packet to
be as similar as possible to the input
data so the idea behind the auto encoder
normally they will introduce information
bottleneck for the encoder part means
you want to learn a concise
representation of the input data and
then the decoder will then how can i
reconstruct the original signals from
the concise representation to make it as
similar as to the input data they are
quite a lot of different variants of the
standard auto encoder so for example the
variation order encoder will try to
encode the input data to the parallel
Terr of the data distribution instead of
the data itself because you will allow
you to do the sampling out of this
distribution to generate the new samples
and for time series the Elstein and auto
encoder will replace the MLP with the
STM to try to learn automatic learn the
feature which can better represent the
time series right so that the matter we
are talking about later as we can is
independent about what kind of auto
encoder you use it you reckon you can
apply different variants of the auto
encoder but for the talk I will use the
most in the MLP auto encoder and this is
the general the framework how to apply
the auto encoder for an orbit detection
so during the training phase you are
given a collection of a subsequent
subsequence windows by encoding and
decoding these subsequent windows you
get the reconstruction error so the
arrow will be back propagate through the
network to update data network allow it
to learn to minimize the reconstruction
error from the input to output and then
after the model is chained for online
detection a new sub sequence window will
pass through the network
encoded and decoded then you can compute
the reconstruction
reconstruct arrow from that so if the
new input sub sub sequence windows the
essential information is different from
the training data then your model cannot
wear reconstruct it so you will get a
high reconstruction arrow and that's how
the anomaly was detected so now I want
to go to the the coop about how to how
the new methods we call it auto-encoder
forest is designed so I would go to the
motivation so the first thing I want to
talk about is there's a key challenge if
you want to directly apply the
autoencoder so this is one I owe t time
series example I highlight two windows
one is the common daily profile another
one is actually an outlier it's a
special event so this is the common
daily profile for this chilla the
cooling towel system this is the special
event the Edit Bay the cooling tower the
fan is not a known but if you directly
apply the auto-encoder
you turn a single autoencoder from the
whole data set you can see actually the
auto-encoder can encode both of the
profile quite well this is not the the
expected reads that we want to see we
want to see you can differentiate right
so the reason is the autoencoder is kind
of self learning so there's no easy way
for you to do something like the cost of
a patient to see how good or how bad the
trend model is so it probably can you
call everything you can encode whatever
the data I pass to do you
you can if I think of everything them
you cannot differentiate that the normal
thing and the normal things but even you
are given this a another scenario you
are given the historical or knobbly
examples it still face this issues
because the whole the training data set
has a lot of varieties so if you train a
single model on that you're you the
model must able to cover all the variety
inside your data so I would use a
synthesized example to illustrate this
so suppose this is the data set you are
given and one project to 2d space is
something that is so you can see there
are multiple structures inside your time
series
so when you
uses single auto-encoder to model is if
I seen you cover the whole space cover
every single structure then this
industry you cannot avoid some area I'll
serve the data so your industry involve
the area like for example in the middle
this is the data this is the area
outside the data and where the unseen
anomaly may appear in here in future so
so that idea may be very simple right so
instead of actual thinking is there how
about I build multiple models one focus
on individual structure of the cluster
and by doing this you now you only try
or pass to every single model will
really focus on the specific pattern the
the training data positive and you were
very you will try to avoid as much as
possible the unnecessary area you try to
evolve so this is the the motivation
about the challenge and the basic idea
underlying the auto-encoder forest we
try to do the power so if you up
the list can view so the nature idea is
like how now the question is how you
identify the different caste inside of
Ava then you can train the individual
autoencoder
so from the previous illustration you
might think the most intuitive way is
that a private class trained on the data
then for each detected cluster I will
try to learn auto-encoder phone man but
it won't work actually you will fail if
you try the the clustering on the
subsequence because the Eamonn and Jesse
ha has studied this problem in their
paper so they fall interesting
phenomenon about the clustering the
subsequence is meaningless the their
conclusion is that no matter what kind
of the time series data is if you apply
the cross string on the subsequence the
the detected cluster Center will be
something in I show in the in the right
figure is something similar to the sine
wave so means if you apply the crusting
on that based on a subsequence the
caster you get actually the variety of
the data doesn't didn't reduce you still
remain the same because it covered a
full spectrum of the the sequence so the
question is then if we the cost
constraint doesn't work then what kind
of information we can rely on to get the
different group from the data so what we
try to explore is the time information
which is naturally available in any kind
of time series so this is the example so
given the time series if you can be able
to detect the repeating period from the
the time series for example they say
this is the time series its pattern
repeat every day then according to how
many point you sample within a period
within a day you can allow all the
sub-windows something at the same time
so for example if it's a daily pattern
is sample at every hour right so 5
o'clock by a.m. in the morning if you
collect all that the the subsequence
window a lie on the fire and across the
last three months
this is naturally a cluster because it
shows you the similar subsequence
patterns from the data so by doing this
we actually a boy
and I mean not working solution to apply
to Christine we naturally use the
available information about a time in in
the time series but I just want to
highlight our alignment is not directly
based on the time stamp so just now I
highlight an example the daily profile
but the period could be anything
for example your period can be 3 hours
then your actual time stamp is not
exactly the same you basically need to
say you need to put the index on your
sampling data and let's say the first
sampling point of every period this is
my first cluster the second sampling
points of all the purists in my training
data this is the second cluster again so
is it clear
I hope it's clear so this is a core part
of the our methods or autoencoder
forests once you know this group then
the idea is very simple for each group
now you train a single an individual
autoencoder
based on this subgroup of the data only
I want to talk a little bit about the
actual training of the autoencoder so we
didn't spend a lot of effort on find you
the architecture of the auto-encoder
so instead we fix the structure like
auto-encoder has two layer of encoder
each one try to reduce the input
dimension to half and we have two layers
of decoder each one try to increase the
input dimension to two times right so
the activate function we all use the
relu expect the last layer we use the
linear activation function so the the
idea to use the standard standard
structure and the standard training
process we use the early stop mechanism
to stop the chaining if the benchmark
performance is rich otherwise we run the
maximum number of epochs before the
training is complete so what we want to
try to achieve is like we want to use
this standardized architecture and
training process to train on every
single in individual auto encoder across
different type of the IOT stream to
avoid to reduce the cause to avoid
unnecessary customization that's how we
want to
chief like lower down the cost of the
solution push the adoption for this and
actually we found it works quite well
across different type of the auto
encoder the reason I probably can
explain is because now the training data
for every single auto encoder is very
focused because I only pass the subgroup
which you only have one or two at least
a lot more less than the whole data set
to the auto encoder it really can focus
on this pattern only
and this is the reside on the
demonstration so previously show for the
two patterns which are very different
single auto encoder actually can encode
them quite well but if you apply the
auto encoder forests to them now you can
see you can differentiate the two
profile two to provide for the normal
profile the auto encoder will encode it
quite well for the unusual profile the
auto encoder now cannot reconstruct the
signal very well right but I want to
highlight a key for the auto encoder
forests even though we have a map to
models in this case the two windows HD
is encoded by the same auto encoder
because they are a lie in the same time
so it's not because the and now I use
the different encoder to encode it and
they can differentiate it still using
the same single auto encoder but this
time this encode the only trend with a
specific pattern
it won't be confused by you you give
them a lot more pattern to learn
so so this is the example I hope I can
illustrate to the audience to make you
understand where's the motivation and
how we deny it and what's the imperative
effect this solution applied when you
apply on the real situation so next I
want to talk a bit about the intuitive
workflow so once you've had a solution
to really try this solution we need to
automate it we need to make it as a
service so this is the cinder and to an
afro for chaining the time series data
will go through we need to apply some
ties if it's time series and SS and
processing after this two-step the
rolling window and every data points
will be extracted as the training data
from there we train the auto-encoder
forests which they see a collection of
the autoencoders and this will complete
a training phase and for the anomaly
detection flow the new test data will be
passed to similar processing and
analysis will be a cry on the test data
and the rolling window of every single
point will be a check and will be sent
to the auto encoder a specific auto
encoder will be pickup and score the the
sequence and this is how you can get the
anomaly score and there are some very
important analysis part we I want to
highlight first it's about a purity
pattern analysis because we need this
purity to determining every data point
which cluster it belongs to so the idea
behind is we will compute a local
maximum of the autocorrelation and we
will get the more of the interval
between any two local maximum points and
you can see from this example is it's a
time series data with every five minutes
sampling points it shows that ad
patterns even though there are some a
lot of deviation but in even in this
case the proposed message still be able
to detect correctly the daily pattern as
the purity
there's another processing important
processing I would highlight is about
the missing data Henry so for the IOT
times you is there space the
specific things about misalignment
because you know the sensor sending the
data due to the sensor issues and
network issues sometimes the interval
even though it's fixed
but the real data sent in it there's a
mr. Liman so for example in in the top
example the the data actually is
supposed to come in at 4:30 but the data
come in 1 minutes late this is what I
call a misalignment in this case
actually there's no data missing
you just need to align the data points
and in the second case it's like if if
really there's a big gap about more than
two times of the interval you don't have
the new data comes in this is situation
you have a missing value so to feel the
the missing value we have a two strategy
if the gap is very small we will use the
nearby value to fill in the missing data
if the curve is very big then we will
use the same pure this the medium value
of the same sampling point from the
other period to fill in the gap and this
is a normal score again we want to put a
non score very simple so the idea is
like we will get the the rolling window
from the test data but we don't want to
score the whole windows so in in the
first portion we use the medium profile
to fill in the the window and only that
the last key points are actual value and
when this data were passed into the land
auto-encoder forest a specific
autoencoder will be selected and use it
to reconstruct the signals and finally
that Euclidean score was compute between
the last key points to compute a
reconstruction error so I will quickly
go through a few examples to highlight
what is the performance and the benefit
for this method so this is the time
series data about a cool water return
temperature from the cooling tower so
you can see this is a this is a time
series something every five minutes and
they are the it shows a strong daily
pattern but there's a lot of
knobblies some anomalies is about the
sensor issues some of normally it's
about a miss operation
some special events from from the from
the left bottom figure this is our
anomaly score chart so you can see the
the solution actually successfully
detect loss very obvious anomalies about
the extreme values
he also detects some very subtle
anomalies for example like this part is
it's a special event corresponding to
this unknown risk oh and also there's a
flat line indicate the sensor for which
is highlight in here right so because
our methods assigned a real a novice
call for every single data points so it
allowed the customers actually to
progressively select different level of
the according to the severity different
level of normally to take action so he
can look at the the top enormous go
first and then you can go down to a more
subtle an old score then the user HD can
find you say what kind of level what
kind of a percentage I want to see in
the future about anomaly this is another
time the IOT time series about the sheer
water return time he found the cheetah
and similarly this is the time series
about the 15 minutes sampling rate and
there's a strong sampling irregularity I
mentioned misalignment in this time
series but as I introduced before our
our solution can have able to handle
this kind of irregularity quite well and
you can see it's a three detect the very
obvious nabhi here and also detect some
kind of misaligned miss operation
pattern so you can see the besides the
top normally the rest of memory is about
a single pattern is like in the morning
the the cure water temperature was
significant drop and then come back this
is something unusual compared to other
days the other day is that when the
temperature go up and then you will
immediately go to the normal range but
in these few anomalies you can see the
temperature always go up first go down
very significantly and compare again and
the last example and highlight this is
our smomid data so it's a is for
industrial environment it's not in your
household but similar to
how so is there every half-hour
electricity consumption so that from the
prune blue graph you can see this is the
original signals actually for human it's
not easy to identify what is that nobody
there but after our solution up right
you can see very clearly a few uh
normally pop up with a very high anomaly
score and if you go into the detail
about how the auto encoder reconstruct
the original signal actually it provides
some explanation why a point was written
as a nobly by the model because for
example in this day you can see the
model actually expect there is no
significant jump at the afternoon 2:30
p.m. but the the input signal which is
deviated from what model belief has a
huge jump consumption around this time
so I think that it is belong a the just
prep box the auto encoder that way how
he can reconstruct the input signal
actually provide some information for
the stuff to understand why there's a
knobby what kind of already happened in
this period of time ok so this what I
want to share that's all thank you
[Applause]